fans of Jersey Shore know how crazy it
got between Ronnie and Jen they put
often when they were together and the
police even got involved but now they
are putting their baby first
as our Sophie show Lacey found out and
heard school say visit with Ronnie at
home we've got some footage of dad and
mom having some crazy times have you and
Jen talked about when there might be an
appropriate time to leave her in I'm
she's older 15 16 well you like block
the Google servers yeah describe your
little girl to me uh she's she's
thinking she's a character she really is
she's uh she's a lot of fun she's got a
lot of personality I don't like a look
at her parents so kinda makes sense
14 month-old Wiggly little Ariana and
they not be so steady on her feet but
she's already a camera loving meatball
just like her dad she loves the cameras
say I'm ready for my close-up she's like
got already got like a hundred thousand
followers on Instagram go girl
Ronnie and Ariana's mom Jen Harley broke
up just after her birth they shared
50/50 custody and have a very healthy
co-parenting relationship she's always
gonna be the mother of my child and you
know I feel like me and Harry were
always gonna have love for each other
but right now we're both happier in the
situation that we're in believe it's too
late to turn back now
Jersey Shore a family vacation returns
July the 11th on MTV it's hard to
believe that between the cast they now
have eight kids what would you do if
they if MTV came to you and it's like
okay we're doing Jersey Shore 2.0 kids
are going together
not my kid monkey see monkey do ya know
and I don't see things I did that's for
sure
well Ronnie what's Terry's gets clear of
plastic surgery in May he appeared on
the doctor's where he underwent
liposuction on his abs I think my body
was just like what are you doing why
would you do this to me you can't do 30
minutes of cardio like come on thank you
would you advise other dads to I would
tell them just do cardio
very good advice now by the way the new
season of Jersey Shore family vacation
will show how Mike the situation
Sorrentino is doing behind bars he's
serving eight months for tax evasion and
the gang goes to visit him in prison
you
[Music]